bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors comment avez vous réagi à
la lecture de ce document ce matin bon
tout simplement que ça confirme que
l'entreprise n'est pas sérieuse que le
préfet la dréal seraient passés à côté
c'est difficile à croire le dirigeant
cette usine celles et ceux qui prennent
des décisions au détriment de nos vies
doivent être sanctionnés voilà ils ont
failli trop de reprise n'est en danger
la population
voilà les élus c'est pareil il faut les
sanctionner
il faut les sanctionner par le vote
faire barrage au candidat trop libérale
pro industriel respirer un air sain et
un droit c'est un devoir aujourd'hui
c'est même une nécessité vitale l'avons
compris à nos dépens les industriels
jouent avec notre santé et ça peut plus
durer
alors comment se porte aujourd'hui la
population rennaise presque plus trois
mois après la catastrophe il était
notamment question de relever un
sanitaire en fin d'année dernière pour
évaluer les conséquences
sanitaire de cet incendie sur les
rouennais la population est en colère en
effet il ya toujours pas de suivi
sanitaire
les analyses faites sur le sol sur les
denrées alimentaires sont vraiment trop
peu c'est inadmissible
l'état nous abandonnent complètement
vraiment donc toujours pas de relever
sanitaires pour évaluer les dégâts
causés sur sur la population toujours
pas et pourtant c'est pas le fait de les
alerter ans tous les jours au quotidien
eh bien il faut croire qu'ils sont
sourds eux aussi comme cette usine cette
cuisine à cancer comme on l'appelle ici
ce qui signifie qu'il n'y a plus de
discussions aujourd'hui avec les
autorités locales nationales
il reste comme sur leurs positions
malgré toutes les informations qu'on
arrive à avoir
malgré toutes ces informations comme la
la c'est grave je veux dire des experts
en assurance qui sont plus performants
que la dréal plus performants que les
temps qui demandent cette mise en
sécurité qui n'est pas fait on nous a
vendu cette usine tout au début comme
une usine sécurité à la pointe est en
réalité il n'en est rien il en est tout
autre même c'est inadmissible c'est
inconcevable
ce genre d' usine de disparaître du
paysage c'est pas normal qu'elle existe
encore il est question aussi de
dédommagement ou est-ce qu'on en est sur
ce point pareil c'est une belle arnaque
aussi un on laisse à l'industriel tous
les pouvoirs donc évidemment lui
son but c'est de lâcher un un minimum
d'argent voire même ne pas indemniser du
tout puisque pour lui aussi il a
présenté ses excuses donc il s'arrête là
il n'y a aucune indemnisation c'est pas
normal
le peuple doit le peuple rouennais et
son agglomération doit sanctionner
sanctionner ces élus qui sont laxistes
qui font confiance à l'industriel et il
va falloir aussi que les les la
population vraiment soient vigilantes et
sortons pour montrer leur mécontentement
parce que c'est pas normal
cette cuisine aller au pied au cul de
nos habitations au pied de nos enfants
c'est catastrophique ce qui se passe en
france est vraiment catastrophique
malheur au delà des sons des sanctions
que vous évoquez
à l'instant je rappelle que vous êtes
donc président de l'association des
sinistrés de lubrizol
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que les
sinistres est que vous représentez
demandé très concrètement aujourd'hui on
demande que justice soit faite puisque
l'état est sourd donc il ya une
instruction qui est en cours à nous
d'apporter tous les éléments au juge
tous les éléments je vais donner un
exemple par exemple les fiches produits
les fiches produits ont été mis à
disposition sur le site de la préfecture
et personnes s'en saisit c'est nous qui
sommes en train de faire ce travail un
travail difficile long parce qu'il faut
des chimistes il faut comprendre il y a
énormément de manquement d'informations
sur 7 sur ses fiches
cc c'est à l'image de ce que démontre
cette usine depuis le début c'est à dire
un je m'en foutisme à toutes les preuves
ils sont au dessus des lois au dessus de
tout le monde merci pour votre élection
simon de carvalho président de
l'association des sinistrés de lubrizol